you see the mitt romney stuff no okay
this is uh them confronting mitt romney
at an airport
how are you doing
don't tell me what to do it's required
by law in the circle i'm standing six
feet away i'm sorry
okay i'll tell you what because you know
what i'm gonna go ahead and do it
because i want to have a chat with you
why aren't you supporting president
trump i do support
this is so cringe man this is why just
let it go man just
why don't you suppose pretty neutral
that is wow
i hate mitt romney but this i hate i
[ __ ] hate i hate mitt romney
probably more than most people hey matt
why come you don't
support president trump but it wouldn't
bother him at an airport hey excuse me
excuse me i'm gonna talk to you in just
a moment put my mask on finishing my
cinnabun
and when i finish my cinnabon you know
i'm gonna go down to the starbucks there
at terminal b i'm gonna get me a coffee
i'm gonna come back we're gonna sit down
i wanna know why you don't support
praying talk
[Laughter]
president trump does it i think i agree
with you're not supporting him
i'm sorry i do agree with many of the
things he
is for and i support those things are
you going to support him in the
uh the fraudulent votes mitt romney
and i again i hate mitt romney he's a
neocon piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] did you see
now
uh mitt romney this this is him on
that's on getting on the flight
know what we think
okay now i'm see forget all this this is
where i
this is where i [ __ ] really get angry
i love it i love it don't
i don't care what your political belief
is i don't give a [ __ ]
don't bother people on an airplane in a
movie theater
or while they're having dinner i
if a baby was crying on an airplane
everybody and i'm not saying bother
because you're not just bothering mitt
romney right
you're bothering everybody else it has
to fly everyone else on the plane that
has the fiat
[ __ ] be in there again is this cool
is this part of is this gonna win trump
the election
is this gonna win the country back is
this gonna have us have the senate
are we gonna have are we gonna be able
to put trump right in the white house
we're gonna lock her up dude
it's not gonna what don't do this on an
airplane
because if we've played same videos of
the remember the black woman that was
doing this on the airplane talking about
black lives matter we were queens
everybody was like she's [ __ ]
annoying how dare you do this on an
airplane this is [ __ ] terrible
what is your problem why would
you do this
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] well that's why look
i'm just and i just want to put it out
there again i know i've been saying it's
a lot like
illuminati uh globalists soros democrats
call me call me somebody's [ __ ] they
deserve it fine
but that's why i wasn't even at did you
see me get as mad about the video before
when she was just bothering mitt romney
but now your annoyance is bothering 200
other people
in a metal sphere in the sky and also
how is being cringe like
how that's what i don't understand like
wow we showed mitt romney
it was like five minutes of mild
unpleasantness for him
in exchange for a video that will last
forever that will make you
look cringe like what what's the
trade-off
because you can shout at me on a flight
and make a scene and make an ass see
yourself and videotape it
but as soon as i get to wherever we're
going and i go out of the airport and i
can't
have i'm going to forget all about what
happened on the plane
but now you're on video looking forever
i meant cylinder i know i said sphere i
meant cylinder um
but this this right here is so
it is so annoying [ __ ] but again
[ __ ] them they deserve it so when
someone someone [ __ ] crazy
that they was they was there was we was
kings person does it on a plane
in their mind they feel that the white
people deserve it are you fine with that
of course you're not no one's fine with
this can you imagine the person on that
plane right now that's sitting there has
to go to the
probably going to their father's funeral
like because you're on a plane you're
like you can't go to the funeral you're
right fair enough
fair enough you're not allowed you're
not allowed to go to funerals you are
allowed to go to a protest though yes
um
if they were chanting anything else
on a plane would you be okay with it
that's all i'm asking they were chanting
anything else on a plane would you be
okay with it would you be fine you would
be fine
with being annoyed you would be fine
with sitting on a plane while they were
chanting this yes
yeah this is one of those where you go
excuse me excuse me uh i'm gonna need
you to shut the [ __ ] up
like for real because something's good
something's about to spin wildly out of
control on this plane
i i this this is i mean again man i'm
just gonna
this is this is funny to me i again it's
it wouldn't have been the same like if
the left had lost again
they've already spiraled for four years
straight
that they've already got like a lot of
sort of
a lot of it out of their system i feel
like and it would have just been more
moping and more pissing and moaning and
calling people nazis
and i you know look i we needed to shake
things up things have been getting a
little monotonous
so now we get to see how the right wing
spirals and and i'm
again i'm gonna be a casual observer i'm
gonna laugh at it i'm gonna have fun
with it
it's it's you know sure there's gonna be
things about it
uh we were talking about it off the air
there's gonna be things about it that
suck
you know gonna have to [ __ ] pay more
taxes there's gonna be more
censorship there's gonna be a lot more
having to be creative to stay
alive in 2021 but you know what
that'll be fine you're going to be fine
so i'm going to enjoy
i'm going to laugh at this there's no la
there's nothing left to do but to laugh
as these people
become the right wing equivalent of no
for four years yeah i mean
again some somebody said in the show
what should you let the cities burn
if you want to explain to me logically
how yelling at mitt romney
in an airplane is going to stop riots in
minneapolis
i'll hear you out i really will i will
hear you out i'll hear you out
if because maybe i'm missing like some
sort of jeff goldblum connection
that i haven't i haven't beasted
together
and it's it's weird because now it's
like you know you'll see stuff like
uh yeah wow real cringe boomer take and
it's like
we're now i'm telling you we're at the
precipice we're now watching
the mega people become what the hillary
people were four years ago
they're gonna cling to the same memes
they've been using for four years
the same tired yeah okay boomer yeah oh
like
that's not based in red pill like it's
it they're gonna become
remember what we said for four years
that the left became these broken
westworld robots
yeah and they just went on this
repeating [ __ ] loop and they broke
down
now i'm just gonna watch it happen to
the right way it's gonna play out
exactly the same way and it's gonna be
funny watching me
uh yeah um the okay nice nice boomer
neocon take is gonna be the new
um okay sweaty who hurt you it's gonna
be
it the same [ __ ] script
with the words all slightly changed the
character's name slightly changed
completely the same [ __ ] script it's
gonna be hilarious so then
so then so the next time mitt romney's
gonna vote he's gonna vote on something
he's gonna go
you know i was gonna vote in a neocon
way but then i remember they screamed at
me on an airplane
it wasn't gonna do anything guys come on
man no he forgot about it the moment he
got off that plane
and as i said now that video's there
forever where you look [ __ ]
i see i would have lost it already i
know
chanting anything at that point yeah
yeah mitt's going to resign from the
senate because a bunch of q and on
people are screaming at him
in a jet blue flight can you even
remember the last time you got on an
airplane and your attitude was this
all right in the plane we're gonna go on
a trip yay like
i'm already in a mood if i'm on a plane
and you're gonna start chanting loudly
in this little tube
in this little metal tube like i don't
think i could have made it
a couple of seconds of been chanting
before i screamed
and you know what the worst part is is
that you would have probably been the
one that gets kicked off the plane
shut the [ __ ] up and they would have
came up kicked that
[ __ ] off the plane
me in the back with a burger king crown
on
kick these [ __ ] cringe movers off the
plane connection
and joe biden mitt romney your
constituents
okay well first off i already can't take
this person seriously because they're
not filming with the phone held sideways
so sorry can't take you seriously
why is it at all these cringe maga
things it's always a woman speaking
you know that was one of the major
things that killed your [ __ ] the whole
[ __ ] thing was
every one of these events that i've seen
it's some woman shrieking on a
microphone and i'm like this
is just this ugh you you let all these
[ __ ] blonde and by the way when i see
these blonde
that you let speak for your movement
they're all like
these aging crow's feet washed up
strippers and [ __ ] like mindy robinson
like there hasn't been any you know what
i mean all the respectable women you had
anywhere near any sort of movements
like um like ann coulter and all these
other ones you guys ran them off
the minute they started critic by the
way
dishing out valid criticisms about trump
everybody ran them out of the movement
and replaced them with these dumb bimbos
that will just go
yeah mega baby no matter how many
[ __ ] bump stocks trump takes away
no matter how much money he gave to
israel no matter how much he no matter
how little he did about tech censorship
and all that [ __ ] we just went now mega
baby
you can't look you got to support our
pregnant and you've replaced all the ant
cultures and all the michelle malkins
with these
wrinkled disgusting b-level actresses
that are just shrieking into these
megaphones and
again we get what we deserve
like listen to that listen to this woman
and tell me
why she should be allowed to speak for
out of everybody on that plane
out of all the trump supporters they
couldn't sit around and elect somebody
within the group
that's less shrill
it's never us you know what let me read
some of these she
actually sounds like hillary clinton
when you listen to this woman on the
plane she sounds like hillary
you know what i call her killery i just
made that up oh
snap dude i just made that up because
like yeah because they kill people bro
well that's a way better reason to call
her that
[Laughter]
[ __ ]